folks
if the definition of recession is two
quarters in a row the gdp
slows down
today's what date i believe today's what
date today is the 30th 30th of june
tomorrow is officially day one of
recession oh [ __ ]
if it's two quarters in a row tomorrow
is officially day one of recession and
watch no one talk about it wow
watch no one talk about it until first
quarter of 2023. loretta mester says fed
is on track for three quarters of a
point uh
increase in july rate high go a little
higher go a little higher to see what
this article says can zoom in a little
bit
uh federal reserve bank of cleveland
president lauren says the u.s central
bank is on track for another big
interest rate hike next month based on
current economic conditions if the rate
setting federal open market committee
meeting was being held today miss messer
said wednesday on cnbc that she would
advocate for three she would advocate
for three-point coin uh hike rate hike
uh because i haven't seen the kind of
numbers on the inflation side that i
need to see in order to know
in order to you know that we can go back
to
50 basin basis point increase wow mrs
messer said high readings of inflation
mean the fed needs to raise rates
quickly to restrain
those forces so far this year the fed
has increased its short-term rates
from near zero uh to 1.5 to 1.75 and
officials signaled a number of further
increases are likely
this year as inflation has it afford
your eye oh my goodness okay all right
brace for impact folks
remember when the race
transitory say that again remember when
they told you this was all training yeah
this was transitory well janet yellen
you know she's uh
she's a gem
uh pal says no guarantee fed can avoid
hard landing obviously no guarantee fed
can avoid
hard landing how do you process that
statement the recession is coming it's
saying he's he's he's covering his ass
of course he is yeah this is yeah we
can't guarantee it's gonna be a soft
landing of course it's not it's it's
gotten harder the pathways have gotten
narrower powell said
at a european central bank event on
wednesday nonetheless that is our aim
and there are pathways to achieve that
go lower what is your pathway powell
power jumping in the dirt is going to
mention or said is significantly more
challenging
but russia invasion of ukraine fuel oil
prices have jumped 36 of nation
sanctions
okay i i listen this is uh
a real dilemma yeah this is a real
dilemma and this is a this is a real
dilemma look
here's all you have to be thinking about
this is what you have to be thinking
about
if you're a short-term thinker you're in
trouble
if you're a long-term thinker you're
doing fine
a guy who runs a mortgage company in la
i was talking to him yesterday i said
you know you know what you know what
event would sell out right now
maybe can you tell this to mario maybe
we even put it together ourselves we
just booked five we're about to announce
the five speakers at the vault it's
freaking sick
the the two show the two entertainment
alone that we're going to be having many
people will just come for the show but
you'll be surprised who we're inviting
today it's freaking jam-packed more than
the two events vault we put together
combined we'll be announcing that can we
go can we go maybe we'll announce the
next series but i'm gonna say this to
you here
if i was
maybe just make a note we'll do this
event just make a note we'll do this
event and we're gonna charge pretty much
nothing the tickets for this event the
tickets for this event will be
practically on this uh
500 tickets like cheap tickets will do
here's what i'm gonna do
i would put a mortgage event right now
a two-day mortgage event okay
and at this mortgage real estate event
i'm bringing all the godfathers fathers
of real estate from 20 years and by the
way if somebody else wants to do this go
do it i really don't care i'm not going
to be upset if somebody else takes this
and does it before i do so i don't have
to do it somebody needs to do this event
have two thousand
have an event with all the godfathers of
real estate that were around that
they're out in 0807 the ones that were
in in the 90s when real estate took a
crash and have a lineup of all of them
with a panel for two days and have
realtors loan officers only show up
you would sell thousands you'd sell out
the what is this arena here miami arena
with ftx you would sell i was about this
american you would sell at the ftx arena
of realtors and loan officers to sit
down and say
i would have bernanke there i would have
the guys that messed with uh
i would have any one of these guys that
were involved with raids fed all of that
in a room saying guys how ugly is this
going to be tell us so we can prepare
short term is going to be ugly but i
think the guys that are in it for a long
time i think they're going to be fine
sell your exotics sell your patek
philippe watch sell all of that mess uh
wives if you're listening i told this to
wife yesterday
take a break from chanel for three years
take a break from louis vuitton for
three years take a break from hermes for
three years go back to coach no more
neiman marcus no more nordstroms go to
macy's go to walmart i was 17.
tarjay has got a lot of good selection
for you if you want to go there
amazon's got great selection forget
about the name brand for the next three
years rather than driving a bentley go
drive that chrysler that looks like a
bentley yeah rather than driving a
ferrari go get a corvette it looks just
like a ferrari yeah rather than driving
any of the you know the rolls-royce
phantom just go get a nice sedan s-class
it's a hundred grand you don't have to
pay five hundred thousand dollars for
that phantom
just back up a little bit the next two
three years luxuries set them aside you
got a patek philippe watch or rolex go
get yourself a citizen it's still going
to tell you the time maybe get an apple
watch if you want to yeah but it's a
time to take a break so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]